well the war on Gaza is also having
economic repercussions beyond the Gaza
Strip the global credit rating agency
S&P is downgrading Israel's Outlook from
stable to negative The Firm says there's
a risk that the war could spread across
the region resulting in Greater damage
to Israel's Financial system and
security it also predicts that the
Israeli economy will contract by 5% in
this final quarter of 2023 well let's
speak to Alan Fischer he joins us now
from occupied East jerus
Alan what can you tell us about what the
Israeli Army has been saying and that
Hamas is being helped by Iran I can't
imagine that's helping
perceptions just in the last couple of
hours the Israeli Army spokesman has
said that Hamas is being helped by uh
Iran they say that they have avoid
helped them with training the supply of
weapons uh they have also given them
Tech noow and they continue to help them
with intelligence now if you go back to
October the 8th October the 9th there
was a lot of reports about how involved
Iran had been even one report in a an
American newspaper suggesting that Iran
had given the final approval for the
attack but of course the United States
said it had checked its intelligence
agencies and as far as they were aware
Iran had no direct knowledge of the
attack now the Links between Iran and
Hamas are pretty well known uh but the
fact that the Israelis are saying this
is Hamas H this is Iran
this is still ongoing it will certainly
heighten tensions in the area when Joe
Biden has warned other countries not to
get involved in the attack and there are
plenty uh on in the rightwing in Israel
and also in the United States who would
be interested in perhaps uh pushing
harder against Iran and some who would
even consider the necessity of taking
military action against the the
government in tran and obviously we've
were talking earlier about those
economic repercussions there if things
do indeed escalate and spread Alan let
me ask you because we were talking
earlier about erdogan's comments there
in Parliament what's he said about the
relationship between tea and
Israel well of course the relationship
between Israel and Turkey has not been
good if you go back all the way to 2010
there was a flotilla of boats that tried
to break uh the uh The Siege and the
sanctions of Gaza uh they were
intercepted by the Israeli Navy uh many
of the people there were Turkish the the
boat the uh the mavi marara was also
Turkish that led to a real
deterioration in relationships between
turkey and Israel for a number of years
things started get to get better over
the last few years particularly over the
last several months there was some talk
of perhaps even President erdogan
visiting Israel that has now been
completely ruled out by the Turkish
president he said Hamas is not a
terrorist organization it's fighting for
its land there will be no visit and
Israel took advantage of turkey's good
intentions now people are think that
this won't be the end of it and perhaps
there could be further diplomatic
repercussions between the two countries
Alan fiser there with all the latest
lines for us from occupied East
Jerusalem thank you Alan